streitig ist wieder mal waren und
willkommen zu unserem allerletzten
adventskalender an boxen video in diesem
jahr
ich bin ganz gespannt ich wollte
eigentlich keins mehr machen aber da
habe ich noch einen gefunden den ich
unbedingt auspacken wollte denn es ist
ein west wing adventskalender wer ihn
nicht kennt das ist so ein ikea für ein
bisschen reichere menschen ich hab mir
da noch nie so recht was gekauft ich
glaube doch als erster diese kissen sind
das erste was ich mir da jemand vom
geholt habe und sie waren so teuer dass
ich euch nicht mal den preis sagen
möchte und diese adventskalender ist so
groß dass ich hoffe dass erfolglose
möbelt also da werden jetzt keine möbel
drin sein
aber ich hoffe dass da so ich habe keine
ahnung was da drin sein wird das ist so
ein richtiger test test es er war steuer
witz ist mir noch im kopf geblieben 149
euro gekostet das ist ganz gut influenza
im westring bestellen
deswegen bin ich überhaupt auf diesen
laden gekommen und da ich am sonntag ein
aufräum- und dekorieren video drehen
möchte ein nettes hoffe ich einfach dass
hier schöne weihnachtsartikel drin sein
werden blieb sei das gelände groß sind
der amazon surprise adventskalender war
glaube ich auch so groß nicht ganz so
groß aber fast ich habe einfach dass die
investition gut war
die tierchen sind überall verteilt hier
sind welche dort sind türchen
an den seiten nicht okay tschechien noch
mal 1 1 kalenders fraktions und
interieurdesign adventskalenders auch
echt nice
ich glaube wir mit ganz toll mit kris
meeke weil es ist cool wenn man auch
noch nicht so viel weihnachtsdeko hat
dass man wahrscheinlich dass sie täglich
ein neues stück abzubekommen
[Musik]
da haben wir sie sie ist sehr groß sie
fühlt sich sehr hochwertig an ist hier
schon angedeutet ich hoffe die steht
trotzdem gerade ja ich find's cool und
darf man sie halt nur jeden tag muss ich
halt so ein bisschen runter brennen dann
ist man gezwungen jeden tag jetzt hin an
zu machen in meinem letzten video hat
jemand gesagt dass ich auch die preise
reinschreiben könnte machen wir jetzt
auch mit ok diese kerze kostet 24 99 ist
gegen erster artikel gut was da wirklich
hinter türchen nummer zwei
da musste sich jemand auch gut überlegen
wie man das reinpacken kann
das ist ein türchen nummer 23 excuse me
war
es ist einfach ein bilderrahmen mit
seinem goldenen rannten ist schwarzer
samt sogar ein passepartout drin ein
passepartout ist dieses weiße ring was
vor einem bild liegt ein gott ich will
dass gleich alles aufstellen und
dekorieren
was kostet der bilderrahmen wird die
haben nur eine million ist der 10 euro
der ist sogar richtig gut bewertet also
die kerze hat 25 euro kostet und der
kalender 8 sind spreche 43 euro und
haben gerade mal den zweiten artikel
moment kann das sein dass westring so
der letzte grandiose adventskalender
sein wird türchen nummer drei dieses
video bezirkstrainer es tut mir leid ich
freue mich einfach gerade tierisch auf
alles was kommt ist mir egal
kuki kathrin schiemann allawi katar
[Musik]
ja das kann ich jetzt nicht rausfinden
wir stecken jetzt einfach mal fünf euro
türchen nummer vier wenn sie überrascht
davon dass er große sachen gewinnerin
nach dem startdrittel bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte was ist das was ist das was
ist das was ist das was ist das was ich
glaube ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ist
titel was ist ein titel klären und die
kirchentour man warum findet man die
produktion also selbst auf der seite
findet man nicht denkt sich so hört
einfach toll und dann wissen wir was
teakholz von cliff kosten so bei ebay
gibt es einen 2 gb kostet ist 12 dollar
hp langem einfach zwölf euro kostet
dieses titel sind schon bei 60 euro aber
das finde ich extrem schön ich finde
nämlich wenn man dekoriert müssen ja
auch die küchen artikels und bisschen
christmas sie aussehen ein anderer gibt
berlin bald schon ist riesengroß kommen
wir zu türchen nummer fünf türchen
nummer fünf ist leer
also jetzt muss dieser kalendarischen
noch mehr anstrengung ein leeres türchen
wieder gut zu machen es muss
deprimierend sein wenn man dann wirklich
am 5 ein türchen auf machen möchte und
dann ist es einfach leer
die wollen natürlich nur die spannung
aufrecht erhalten wenn man nämlich zu
türchen nummer 6 an nikolaus geht und
dann was richtig kraft ist daran findet
happy socks cute design also ich meine
mittlerweile sieht man ja überall happy
socks happy socks sind einfach happy
socks hat sogar meine größe 36 bis 40 9
euro kosten wie aber ich finde dass die
seien ja kommt ist gut aber wenn man
schon alles im christmas tree macht
warum macht man nicht auch die happy
socks mit einem weihnachts design
kirchengemeinden who keine schneeflocken
lichterkette ist fast so gut dass wir
den kalender als letztes auspacken der
ist richtig weihnachtlich bräuchte ich
noch batterien
ich bin zufrieden kommt stadt ist da ist
man schön
das sind so sachen dafür bin ich immer
zu geizig wenn ich im laden es sehe dann
denke ich mal so oder so eine
lichterkette wurde ein fenster für
schüler sehen und dann denke ich mir so
hole ich mir noch lieber kaffee bei
starbucks kette was kostet du vier euro
82 aber es so ne amerika machen wir mal
sechs euro für die lichterkette die
seite ist ein bisschen beschädigt
tierchen immer 8 ich habe absolut keine
ahnung was es ist ja schon wieder was
von blooming früh also es ist so und hat
ein loch drin
vielleicht komme ich ja noch drauf
absolut ihr wisst was es ist und ich es
nicht rausgefunden ab schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare so viel ich entnommen
eine kiste hülle lässt ohne kissen macht
für kissen köhler war ein bisschen wenig
sinn aber es ist schlagfertig so helle
weihnachtsdeko und nicht so dieses
klassische rot grün baby it's cold
outside ja okay da man ja auf jeden fall
ein kissen rhein hat auch eine gute
qualität muss man sagen es ist richtig
ordentlich ins zeug
haha so wenn wir jetzt diese
kissenhüllen nicht finden
auch zeit mit schriftzug jetzt vierten
säule 19 richtigen nummer 10 wir sind
noch nicht einmal bei der hälfte
angekommen haben schon über die hälfte
des preises zurück grau es weiter
das habe ich jetzt irgendwie gar nicht
erwartet weiß hat und irgendwann noch
drin wir sehen noch ist es aber nicht so
gut wenn man t verschickt muss es schon
luftdicht verpackt sein und vieles
liefen die tiefen loch nicht getätigt
haben wir machen uns interessieren wir
unseren tee und zur weihnachtszeit muss
man natürlich mit einer c a strange
süßen ist klar
zu gast sind von lecker schmeckt unser
west wing thw kiel 24 minuten sondern
ziehen weil er sonst extrem bitter wird
und ich glaub ich hab ihn zu
sanktionieren versetzt mich sofort in
die christmas i stimmung was kostet denn
so ein tb west wing natürlich finde ich
denn jetzt nicht
ja das ist ja 15 euro kostet der ok
schmeckt der tee gleich viel besser
kommen zu den elf special delivery von
haye
und das kann man auch so bald wieder
verwendbares geschenkpapier nehmen jedes
jahr kann man sich dann dagegen sagte
schwarz schenken wenn man es auch kriegt
das gefällt mir gut mir gefällt aber
auch jeder artikel hier auch in die
happy socks zu nehmen wir immer noch
enttäuscht für die person die das
vorgeschlagen hat das jedem man immer
die preise aus suche ja denke wer ihm
als scherz finden leute ich gebe nicht
auf ich glaube ich gibt gleich auch aber
eigentlich will ich nicht aufgeben
ich hab mich gefunden also sie sagen mal
fünf euro beim westring ist ein bisschen
überteuert türchen nutzen will
[Musik]
wunderschön mit tasten wird eine kerze
brennt schöne tasse diese echt schön com
war die gefällt mir richtig gut wird
auch die perfekte größe habe ich
irgendwie nach falschen welt aber recht
10 euro kommt mir so vor kirchen immer
bereit für ein kitsch ein solches noch
nie gesehen ein schlüsselanhänger
ich darf beispiel schon wieder alle
pakete von meinen nachbarn annehmen also
keychain ein schlüsselanhänger mit so
einem metallischen dicken wort das habe
ich noch nicht gesehen nach westring ist
lass mich doch einfach diesen artikel
auf deiner seite finden
[Musik]
und möchte mit ihr gerne reden ja nicht
schlimm ich habe gerade pakete
angenommen und ruhig bleiben muss in
brüssel
ich stand gerade druck alles gute damit
tür und hab gerade für die nachbarn
pakete angenommen und dann laut alexa
angefangen zu klingeln ilona möchte mit
ihnen sprechen und den kopf und dann
guckt mich an als ob ich sonst was
machst du jetzt gibt was hast du jetzt
gemacht hast du anrufst was musst du
jetzt machen dass du anrufst also der
schlüsselanhänger kostet glaube ich zehn
euro wenn noch mal zehn euro ich bin den
auch nicht also ich drehe gerade ein
videoteam quito alles gut was ich auch
nicht regatten video und packe einen
adventskalender das klingt schon mit
einer debatte
quito alexa
ist einfach gerade mal 41 king seine tür
als minister ja ich in den forst
erwartet ich bin du bist du das wort
krise er hat nicht angerufen da der
gerade aufgelegt und dann hat er mich
angerufen während ich gerade im paket
angenommen haben und dann stehe ich da
eine tür unseres pakete an und dann
kommt ja ich möchte sie an uns ganz laut
über die ganze wohnung und der paketbote
guckt mich an und nicht so ja ich möchte
gerade angerufen und er so lese nicht so
in meiner lexa und jetzt habe ich zurück
angerufen funktioniert auf sechseinhalb
stunden später
habt ihr das gerade mitbekommen es hat
dann natürlich klingt dann hat mein
bruder angerufen dann hat es nochmal an
der tür geklingelt hat dann muss ich
mein bruder zurückgerufen dann kamen
noch mal was wenn jetzt gleich die
nachbarn anfang hier rein zu kommen um
die pakete abzuholen jetzt alle bei mir
abgegeben worden dann ganz natürlich
gerne für meine nachbarn falls dass ihr
nachbar sid ich nehme ich natürlich
gerne mal die pakete an home office ne
super ja wir kommen nicht voran gemacht
da haben die sich alle abgesprochen eine
schlafmaske kilo aber aber dies schön
die will ich glaube ich wirklich für
mich benutzen die sleeping beauty einmal
das ist eine ganz sachte sachte eimers
können sie passt perfekt zu meinem auto
fährt jetzt sie fühlt sich sehr sehr gut
an und ist sehr locker ich mag es nicht
wenn augenmasken so eng sitzen weil ich
so einen dicken kopf hab jetzt im winter
ist es dunkel nonstop augenmaske na komm
ja das ist sie das ist sie nicht
20 euro das meine ich westring
das sind so designer sagen also wir sind
jetzt schon über den einkaufspreis von
diesem adventskalender nämlich bei 162
euro 99 christmas konfetti merry
christmas die sind wunderschön und sie
passen perfekt zu meiner tasse was
kosten servierten bei osc lille okay die
kosten 54 euro für möglich vier euro 5 2
für servette
na ja schöne verwirklichen nummer 16
sowas habe ich noch gewartet wheelbase
kleine christbaumkugeln sehr
geschmackvoll auch von dekor is
christmas ja wie finde ich die jetzt ja
so was ungefähr was kostet zehn euro
diese rechnerei aber gut dass wir nach
geschaut haben wirklich gut weil wenn
man den preis weiß dann ist das noch mal
ein ganz anderes ding hier kirche nummer
flor de sal getränk natural science
meersalz schön kann man das jetzt da ja
wie geil ich liebe so dekadent ist salz
war das schmeckt so gut wenn man sich so
ein frühstücksei
und dann soll er seine aus mallorca
warte mal mein gott nicht dein ernst ok
story teil
ich war dieses jahr auf mallorca im
urlaub eine woche ein freund hat uns
empfohlen auf die ganz andere seite der
insel zu fahren zum strand es trenc es
wird anders ausgesprochen und sie
verstand liegt so ganz versteckt ist
aber wunderschön und wir sind an so
einem salz dingen vorbei gefahren wo
salz abgeschöpft wird und ich habe noch
gedacht schade dass wir uns da nicht so
ein bisschen salz mitgenommen haben weil
das eine schöne urlaubserinnerung war
dieses salz kommt auf mallorca es trenc
also aus diesem salz wegen was ich
gesehen habe
wow das ist egal wie viel das kostet das
hat einen großen emotionalen wert
das ist ja froh dass sein dass der ist
trendy hier lesen hier zeigen sie noch
einmal den ort zieht geil ist das denn
bitte
jetzt bin ich gespannt was es kostet
zehn euro
18 bist du bloß eine hand maske also
eine maske die man sich auf die hände
aufsetzt made in korea
ich liebe diesen adventskalender ich
kann euch nicht anders sagen erst dieses
salz jetzt dass eine kostet vier euro
net schlechter sprich nach arbeit wieder
nagel video und dann benutzt diese maske
türchen nummer 19 da macht man mit dir
das fühlt sich irgendwie ganz komisch an
haben wir ein hirschkopf glaubt man
stellt ihn einfach so hin
vielleicht so als servierten beschweren
oder man kann serviert und vielleicht
hier rein machen das wäre cool
ich werde auch niemals herausfinden was
das ding kostet weil es einfach keine
marke hat oder sonst was ist einfach nur
ein schwarzer hirsch kommen muss ich
allerdings ist aber sagen nicht so
hochwertig aus wie ich es von west wing
jetzt erwartet hätte also die lackierung
hat fehler und so aber ich meine es
schön kann man nicht anders sagen hier
sein depot stück kann ich auch meine
dinger da drauf machen auf meine
untersätze natürlich in nürnberg
die light department easy und läufer
styling jingle bells gelandet
die kann man irgendwo rumhängen ging auf
als ginge die welt ihn nicht finden aber
ich sag mal jetzt spontan fünf euro
würde ich dafür geben türchen 21 chris
de burgh yu na das ist doch mal ein
christmas die quittung paar ideen was
man so machen kann
das finde ich sehr schön muss er nicht
noch mal was firma bade bomben toll
tisch am 22 ein star
okay ist das cool mein gott es ist ein
also dass solche spiegelei seien dann
kannst du dein einer rein machen und
dann hast du einen stern spiegel ein
fantastisch also wir sind jetzt schon
bei 196 euro
das ist dieses firma das ist diese firma
aber zwei okay
mehr will ich dafür irgendwie ausgehen
knacken wir noch die 200 euro mit dem
türchen 23
ich weiß dass diese christmas kugeln
kosten so viel geld deswegen ich freue
mich sehr darüber
ja ich liebe das werdet das in meinen
blog sehen ich habe so viele coole
verschiedene christbaumkugeln
mittlerweile geholt das ist echt das ist
echt schön
dafür gebe ich sechs euro aus diese
dinger sind scheiße teuer wir sind schon
bei 204 euro und jetzt kommt das letzte
türchen ich hoffe kein akku geht jetzt
alle wenn wir machen das letzte türchen
auf kirchen 24 was bekommen wir an
weihnachten leute die haben uns schon so
gefreut
es gab schon so viele sachen und das
bringe es verdammt schwer es gibt sogar
eine karte war
wii sports und best wishes von the
christmas in the heart i follow you a
merry christmas joachim christmas und
mein gott das ist schwer und das kommt
aber diese landschaften lassen bestimmte
zone um 1 corti riecht gut 100 prozent
natürliches wachsmuth in england
aromatherapie aroma therapie parks
origins park scandal
was kostet so eine parks kende das ist
sie 18 euro also 18 euro kostet sie bei
amazon bei us bringen wird sie
wahrscheinlich 20 kosten aber die riecht
richtig richtig richtig schön war nicht
so richtig sauber und siehst du bist als
jack 21 euro für den wir sind bei 224
euro 150 hat er gekostet
dann kriegt man so 70 euro geschenkt
also wieso sie meine ich bin zufrieden
außer das ist eine typische leer war die
nummer 5 wahrlich
das war der us trainer brands kalender
leute ich bin begeistert das kann deine
star gleich alle geht deswegen sage ich
jetzt mal vorsichtshalber tschüss aber
gucken gemacht was sie alles jetzt drin
war
na komm noch schön
außer dieser happy socks was meinten sie
damit kann muss halt schauen würde ich
150 euro für diese artikel ausgeben das
ist die frage
also dann haben sie gut losgelegt als in
den bilderrahmen reingepackt haben
dachte ich so krass das wird richtig
heftig und mit der kerze die jetzt auf
25 euro kostet hat aber es geht also es
sind die hochwertige sachen natürlich
wenn man nicht das geld dazu hat würde
man sich das auch nicht holen und dann
also man bekommt das alles
wahrscheinlich auch günstiger als für
220 euro nähe ist schön
es bringt mich auf jeden fall in
weihnachtsstimmung darum geht es doch
noch und ich würde sagen wir sehen uns
das nächste mal wieder wahrscheinlich
ich habe keine ahnung am ersten also am
2 dezember gehen die blogs los weil ich
auf dem ersten dezember anfange zu
filmischen ein tag vorher an zu füllen
ich muss schon bis zum nächsten leute
[Musik]
als letztes war der letzte
adventskalender
es hat mir in über 20 ländern noch eine
rede
es hat mir sehr viel spaß gemacht dieser
adventskalender auszupacken zum thema
nachhaltigkeit und dass ich immer gesagt
dass das plastikverpackung glas nicht
gut ich kann absolut verstehen wenn
manche leute sagen hey das ist so
doppelmoral und du packst einen nach dem
anderen aus aber das ist ja auch so eine
art live action und das ich sag einfach
das was mir als erstes zu den produkten
einfällt und das ist dann in vielen
fällen hyde ist es nachhaltig ist es ist
es viel verschwendung kann man es anders
machen und ich finde es besser irgendwas
dazu zu sagen
zum thema plastik oder so anstatt ist
gar nicht zu erwähnen weil die
adventskalender auspackt videos die sind
super
die kommen super bei euch an mir macht's
mega viel spaß ich liebe adventskalender
vielleicht erzähle ich auch irgendwann
mal warum aber wisst was ich meine und
ich fand es toll dass ihr alle so
begeistert immer zugeschaut habt und das
war's mit den anderen für dieses jahr
geht es wieder weiter deswegen sei es so
und ich mache ich auch ich würde gerne
eigenen anzeigen aber ja beim eisfischen
die ganze reise zu meinem eigenen ansatz
können damit dass wir eigentlich cool
oder
dann fange ich im oktober mit meiner
series an wie ich sahin hat welz
kalender plane um einen anstieg auf ski